[Music]
please join me in welcoming sharla
gelfin
hi everyone thanks for coming i am so
excited to be here
our studio conf is my favorite thing in
the world pretty much
uh and it took me quite a trajectory to
get here so
three years ago i came to our studio
comp for the first time and i lost my
wallet and joe chang had to lend me
money to get home
and now i'm here talking so if anyone
has lost their wallet
cancel your credit cards and please
submit a talk abstract in 2023
so i'm here to talk to you about uh
repeated reporting in the r
universe if you're interested in the
slides they are available at bitly slash
shar studio conf and you may
know me on twitter as charla gelfand and
if not please follow me
so the inspiration for this talk came
from my previous job
where i was a statistician working with
data on ontario's nursing workforce
and at this job we had a set of reports
that we had to write every year released
to the government
and these reports used to be written
using a combination of spss
excel and word with a lot of decisions
kept track of in email and paper notes
the process was pretty manual and it
might sound familiar to some of you
so first we would somehow acquire the
data in a lot of cases this involved
emailing someone from the it team
waiting for them to have time to work on
the project then they would query the
data
and send it to us then we use spss to
clean and explore the data
and make some summary tables we move
over to excel
where there are nicely formatted tables
move the data over a year
and paste the new data in then we go to
word and replace the tables change some
numbers and text
then we discover that there's a mistake
in the data in the report
so we go back and we do everything all
over again
uh this might sound familiar to some of
you so these reports which you had to
write
every year took all year they weren't
reproducible
and things were scattered hard to keep
track of and the
work was boring manual and repetitive
and not easily repeatable
and instead of being able to do new
things on the job we were stuck doing
the same work
over and over again so this is a bit of
a spoiler but i'm sure you knew that
this is going
but first i have to say that i have not
been completely honest
i didn't do any of the previous work my
coworker charlene who is here and
previous statisticians
did this but i started the job knowing
that i had no interest in using spss
so i started the job i took about a week
to understand how things were going how
we made these reports and i was having
lunch with my co-worker and i'm like
hey have you heard of r
it took a week you know settle in um and
she had thank god
so charlene had used r in grad school
and was more than happy to have
opportunities to use it more she had
wanted to improve our processes so she
quickly learned the tidy verse
fell right into the pit of success and
we transitioned all of our projects over
to r
so we got the queries from our database
team we learned about our database
structure
and we used packages like dplyr and
dbplier to query them
then we used tidier janitor and other
tidy verse packages to clean our data
and we used our markdown cable extra and
ggplot2 to write our reports
and everything fit so well almost as if
it was designed to work together
and pretty soon pretty soon our workflow
started looking a lot like my laptop
we were so proud of what we had
accomplished our code was reproducible
and we didn't have to redo everything if
there was a mistake
our code was all in one place and easier
to keep track of and it took a little
bit of time to transition things
but we knew it would be worth it because
we had time to do new things on the job
and next year arrives and considering
that there's 15 minutes left in this
talk
i'm guessing you can tell that things
did not go as expected
but you know like i was feeling good i
go to work on these projects next year
and
as an obsessed our user i was like
there's nothing that can go wrong
we're using r it's foolproof we're all
good and then
i would come back to projects just ready
to knock them off to the to-do list
and see something that looks like this
so i come back to my code
and i'm like okay so we got check
demographic assumptions done
check demographics old code then we have
you know demographics report
copy of demographics report we've got
try cleaning demographics again
untitled.r and so i'm like yeah like i'm
a pretty organized person
but i come back to this and i have just
no idea where to start
things are not named clearly it is a
jumbled mess and i don't know what files
are what
what order to do them in and what's
usable or what's old so i'm like okay
you know this one says done so that's
probably a pretty good candidate to open
it
so i open the code and so i i take the
the data and i'm like
okay so i change the value of a field
for one id why i don't know
and the value of a different field for a
different id again i have no idea why
then i take the data i filter it and i
do some aggregation
and at this point i'm like cool cool
cool cool so i have
i have just no idea what is going on
here because
the code that i was writing was like so
specific for last year's project
and i wasn't thinking about how to reuse
this code so it was salvageable you know
i have to go through
i remember what's what i copy files over
i change filters
but i was so frustrated because we had
stopped using spss
excel and word because things were not
reproducible they were difficult to keep
track of manual and repetitive
not easily repeatable and time consuming
but the way that i was leaving my r code
things were
kind of reproducible difficult to keep
track of
manual and repetitive not easily
repeatable and time consuming
i think you all got it but it's like the
same list
do you want me to explain all the jokes
so uh in order to avoid having this
happen again
i developed a set of approaches guided
by two principles
don't repeat yourself and talk to
yourself and i hopeful
i hope that it's useful for those of you
who use r for this kind of repetitive
reporting
so don't repeat yourself is a concept
from software engineering
aimed at reducing repetition it says
that you should abstract away repetitive
logic
and automate repetitive processes so why
do we want to do this
well copy and pasting your code is
really error prone
and you have to make an update
everywhere that the code appears and
instead of focusing
on what uh changes we're busy focusing
on what stays the same
you've probably all heard the mantra
that if you copy and paste the same code
three times
you should turn it into a function so
functions and packages
are really the core of don't repeat
yourself in our universe
but repetition is also present in
processes
having to redo things remember where
things are remember what you did
is pretty pointless and you might not be
able to abstract away that process but
you can definitely try to automate
things talk to yourself is a concept
from me
that i thought sounded good with don't
repeat yourself
and it basically is just aimed at making
work easier to use for your future self
so
it's way easier to document why you're
doing something now than to remember
why you did it a year ago the goal here
is to focus on your future self instead
of your present self
and just because we write easy to read
code because of the tidy verse doesn't
mean that it actually explains the
motivations of why we're doing something
so with these principles the first thing
i did is i cleaned up after myself
and i needed to do to do this because my
old code was just not reusable
and there was so much repetition of
process having to relearn where things
were
what they did and what to do so you've
seen this before and i think we can
agree that leaving files like this
is just rude like nobody wants that
so the first thing i did to reorganize
that is i separated out data
reference cold reference code and old
code and reorganize things
and name them clearly to communicate
what they're actually doing
i also took advantage of the default
ordering which does things by name
and gave numbers to indicate what order
things happen in
and even if this is all you do next year
when you come back you can just copy the
old code over and go things
go through things in order but in case
things were not obvious
obvious enough from the order i also
started creating this setup file which
is really useful for starting a project
like having a readme or an introductory
vignette when using a new package
this is a good place to explain the
project where to start like if you have
to email someone and what steps to take
and the goal here is to explain how to
do something and why to do something
instead of just leaving an artifact of
what you already did
so this one's pretty basic but it's
hello welcome to the annual demographics
report
step one query the data open the file
and run the code
step two clean the data open the file
and run the code
and once i left my files usable as a
whole i had to start thinking about them
individually
and how i could make going through
things less manually repetitive
and what to abstract away so functions
are a great way to do this
so i had some code to clean and query
data that was a good candidate for this
so if we look at this code we have a
long and complicated sql query or a
dplyr version of it
then you filter the data where the year
is 2019
you have a bunch of code to rename and
select columns
30 various lines to clean up and
summarize the data and some more code to
save the data
so i mean talking through this is boring
and i like to talk so you definitely
don't want to have to run through this
code every time you do it
and the thing with this code is that
everything stays the same and the only
thing that changes is the year
so it's a really good set of code to
turn into a function
where you take what stays the same make
it into the body of the function
and then you take what changes and make
it into the argument of the function
then you don't have to run through this
code copy it or update logic in multiple
places if it changes
i also put this function into the setup
file so that you can just run the
function
and have it query the data rather than
saying go and open 0 1 query data
but abstraction was not enough for me so
i also decided to make my functions
chatty
as an opportunity to talk to myself so
they use this package is amazing for
many many things but i like this obscure
part where you can just print
um ui to your console so if you do
ui info and you say hi it'll print a
little i for info
and hi to the console and you can use
this in your own functions to print
different kinds of outputs to the
console
you can also use code in these functions
so if i set the analysis year to 2019
and i do ui to do in this case i can do
querying demographics data for
analysis year and it'll print querying
demographics data for 2019
in the function so at the end i had a
function
that when i ran it it actually helped me
keep track of what was going on
so you run it and it says querying
demographics data for 2019
and then it tells you where it's saved
because if you're coming back to this
project a year later
you don't really need to track those
things down it'll just tell you
so i knew that not all of my code had
logic that could abstract it
away our projects had a lot of really
specific data cleaning steps there was a
lot of back and forth and a lot of
checking of assumptions
and always some level of human
interaction required
but a big lesson that i learned is that
artisanal data does not require
artisanal code
so we had very very special data like
locally sourced handcrafted new mistakes
daily artisanal data
but the mistake that i always made was
that i was so focused on cleaning that
set of data
and i wasn't thinking about how to clean
a new batch of the data
and i only knew why i had done something
last time and not what to look for this
time
so instead of writing super specific
code i started writing
generalizable code with super specific
instructions
including things on data cleaning who to
ask what to look for and what to do
and this actually gives you time to deal
with cleaning your artisanal data
because you're not wasting time
remembering
how to clean it so we've seen this
before but again what my code used to
look like is that
i would take the data change the value
of a field for one id and the value of a
different field for a different id with
no idea why i had done it
but what i replaced it with is something
that looks like this so first i'm saying
what to do so an example is i want to
check for any cases where the province
is ontario
but outside of ontario is true because
that's obviously not right
and then why to do it because some of
them may have province wrong but some
may have outside ontario wrong
and then you say who to talk to so email
carla i made up a name sounds like my
name it's close enough
and ask ask them to check paper files to
confirm which is correct
and then what to do next so based on the
response update any manually until the
database
is updated because when i started this
job i found it so difficult to keep
track of who to ask for different things
you know like
you have to email that person and if
they're gone you have to email someone
else
so i decided to just codify it so i
wasn't leaving myself wondering
and then to avoid repetition i could
write a function that actually automates
producing the template again
using the use this package so you take
the template
it makes and saves a copy of it and you
can even pass data to it
and finally i put everything together
into a package
a project like this is a great candidate
for making a package and it is not as
scary as it seems
and once i started making packages for
this i started making packages for
everything else in my life
no further details
so why do why do we want to make a
package i mean as i said
making a package is really an ultimate
form of do not repeat yourself
your functions are centralized in a
specific place and it's really clear
where to update them
your templates also have a place to live
and then you can use other functions to
copy and paste data to them
there's robust documentation and you can
share code with your co-workers in a
better way than emailing it or having it
on a network drive
so when all was said and done i had a
package that looked like something like
this
so my functions had a home in the r
directory and then the templates live in
a special place
so you can copy and use them later
there's documentation
in the form of a readme function
documentation in the man folder
and vignettes for detailed usage and
then to put it all together
the setup function pulls the setup
template and makes a new file with the
template
which contains other functions that can
run through the analysis
and then when you run the function to
query the data it does so
and it does so chattely so that it's
abstracting away the logic
but making sure that you know where
things are saved
so i use don't repeat yourself and talk
to yourself
by cleaning up code with clear names and
ordering
i made functions and i made them chatty
to communicate what they were doing
i made automated templates and i made
them prescriptive to help me know what
to do year after year and then
i made a package to put it all together
and using
this form of repeated reporting in r i
had a project that was
reproducible easy to keep track of it
had minimal manual work
was easily repeatable and it freed up
time which i spent making other art
packages
so my takeaway to you is that if you
have a repetitive task that you find
confusing and you're doing the same work
over and over
abstract away or automate what you can
and loudly communicate the rest
or because it's catchier don't repeat
yourself talk to yourself
thank you
we have a few questions on slido already
if anyone wants to ask questions we're
there in track number two
the first one is how do you name your
script if your boss asks you to double
check something
and you end up with another script that
doesn't fit into the
zero one zero two workflow
i would say like if things are not going
to stay the same year after year like
something besides that maybe make a
folder
that has extra things or i mean the nice
thing with this is that it gives you a
fresh copy of the directory which you
can use but you can always add things to
that
another question was as a person who's
never made a package
before how do you make your package
available to someone else within your
organization
without making it public so if your
organization is small you can have
a free git repo that you can have like
up to three contributors in so that's a
good option
i think if you have like a
another form of version control at your
work or if you have a network drive you
can install a package from there even
sending them the source code and they
can install it
using that i know sending the source
code is kind of not the point but
it's possible what are the advantages of
use this as ui info function over a
simple
print call i like the little icons that
come with
use this so there's like a no they they
communicate useful information right
um like there's a little red dot that
might indicate like you need to do
something or there's a check mark that
says like this is where it is and this
is where it's done
it's just a friendlier form of
communicating i think going off of
icons someone asks where are your icon
and picture
people from my what the icons and
picture
people that you use oh the artist is
here i
went to vect easy and this person had
like 400 businessman
images so i chose one for every emotion
i had to cut some but there's a lot uh
there's a lot
we have a few more minutes for questions
so
can you estimate the time trade-off that
is how much additional time did you
spend and how much time did you save in
the long run
uh i think i've done a few iterations of
this
and it does take some time investment um
up front for sure
uh as for the long run um i quit my job
so so you will have to ask my co-worker
charlene
how much time it saves but really like
going through these projects was like
back and forth that sometimes took like
many many months of checking assumptions
so even if you have to do that i think
it's
it's a time investment in the long run
someone else asked a lot of your
recommendations seem
to be software engineering principles
would you
recommend that our users have a formal
education in this field to prevent
some troubles no i have no training in
software engineering at all
everything i know is from jenny bryan so
so i think you're all fine
uh did did you get pushback when
initially transitioning to this work
workflow if so how did you convince them
that this method may be better
yeah i think there there's always
pushback for these kind of things
um but if someone is in like a position
like your boss where they
they want to advance and they don't want
to wait you to have to waste your time
doing the same thing over and over again
i think there's an argument to be made i
think it's a lot easier to keep people
at a job if they're happy and doing work
that they're interested in rather than
like
copy and pasting things over and over
again but i
i don't have a good answer on pushback
uh we have a lot of questions here so i
may share them with you after in case we
don't answer them all
um one recent one is what is the name of
your package
uh this this package the one that you've
created internally uh so we had one
called
rcno the organization was called cno so
you just put r before it
and then we had a report obviously uh we
had a report uh on exams that we wrote
so the package was just called exams
report
i think as long as you don't name it
like deplier
you're likely not to have any conflicts
i think we have time for two more one is
the hardest thing with this approach
seems to be maintenance and sustaining
can you speak to that side of package
development and
functionalizing i think for this
it wasn't as much of an issue because
things were so similar year after year
like the
the point was kind of that things never
changed so you wanted to
like abstract those things away because
it was not useful going through the same
thing over and over again
i think for maintaining um i did not
cover it at all but writing tests for
your package is a really big thing so
if things are changing in your data or
in your code or things that you're
getting being able to keep track of
those
and then the the last question is asking
about
what you use for version control i use
git okay yeah well thank you